what do you know about a heist at a
black market storage facility in
Kazakhstan happened
a couple days ago
it doesn't ring a bell
you know I may not know when a scrub is
pretending to be a human
but I sure as hell know when a human is
lying you know damn well what was in
that storage fault the fact that you
don't know tells me all I need to know
about this new rather old Nick Fury
I think thanos's snap changed you taught
you that no matter how hard you fight
for what's right there's always someone
stronger to undermine you
you seem to forget this old Nick Fury
has 30 years of hands-on experience with
Scrolls
I know the nature of this threat way
better than you ever will
is that your idea of an offer of some
sort of collaboration between us we used
to work pretty well together back in the
day back in the day you would have seen
my rather mediocre bag then coming a
mile away
the fact that you didn't see them coming
means you haven't a hope in Hell of
seeing graphic and his Rebels coming
which makes you as a partner rather
pointless